taken home over a million dollars a
month for the last more than a half
decade and i get asked the question if
that's true why are you so frugal but
the reason why i'm so frugal is because
i've always had cash to reinvest when
opportunities presented themselves the
biggest opportunity for me was always my
business and my own knowledge and so
rather than spend money on things that
had no return i would save my shekels
and i would spend money on mentorships i
spend money on private coaching i spend
money on seminars and workshops to learn
skills that i didn't have and that's
ultimately why i was able to like move
forward faster i don't get a lot of
benefit from consumption-based stuff if
you eat out at a five-star restaurant
every night it costs maybe fifteen
thousand dollars a month well what do
you do with the other nine hundred and
eighty-five thousand at a certain point
money loses marginal utility meaning it
doesn't actually confirm more value to
your life after a certain point at that
point it just becomes a measuring stick
for god knows what but that's why i'm
pretty frugal because i just don't get a
lot of enjoyment out of the things that
cost a lot of money